Hey Vsauce, Michael here.
I'm sorry. Look, I didn't name myself but
apparently
Michael is the ninth most disliked baby name
for a boy -
according to a survey by BabyNameWizard.com
At least it didn't top the charts like the rhyming
a 'den' names - Jayden, Brayden, Aiden.
The most disliked
name for a baby girl, by the way, was
Nevaeh -
'heaven' backwards.
Names can be more than just
controversial - they can also be
just plain wrong, or misleading.
MISNOMERS
And I'm not talking about the daughter of Mr. Nomer.
Over the summer I went to Singapore
and I saw many many things. I saw
an infinity pool, the world's largest
column-less glass house,
beautiful beautiful orchids, including
the laboratories where scientists
genetically design custom orchids
and very very
humid air that condensed all over my cool glasses.
But even after I cleaned my glasses off
I didn't see any Lions.
In fact, it's believed that no Lions have ever
naturally lived
in Singapore, even though Singapore comes from a Malay word for
Lion City.
It's believed that in 1299 when Sang Nila Utama named Singapore,
he mistakenly thought that a tiger he saw was a Lion.
It's a misnomer.
But here
is the biggest mystery of them all, did I
really go to Singapore?
I mean, look at these photos.
That guy certainly looks like me
but he's not exactly like me.
I have made a video about misnomers
and that guy hasn't.
This photo was from May,
and since May I have been to Australia, New Zealand.
The guy in these photos has never been there.
I am similar
to that guy but he's not exactly
me.
We can resolve this problem by realising
that oranges are apples
You see, in Old English the word 'apple' was used to describe
apples, but also any fruit in general.
For instance, dates were 'finger apples' and bananas
were 'apples of paradise'. Cucumber's
were 'Earth apples'.
In French the word for 'apple' acted similarly,
giving us 'Earth apple' for the potato.
In the Middle Ages the old French word for
orange meant 'apple of the orange tree'.
And the Swedish word for orange still means 'apple'
from China because Orange's originated in the East.
But this leads us to an even bigger
question: what came first
orange, the fruit or orange, the colour?
Well, the answer is neither.
The tree came first.
The word 'orange' comes from the Sanskrit
word for the tree
that these fruits grow on.
Before being introduced
to these fruits the English-speaking
world called this colour
not orange, but yellow-red.
The first recorded use of the word
'orange' to refer to the colour,
instead of the fruit, wasn't until 1512.
So the colour was named after the fruit,
which was named after the tree that it came from.
But what's a fruit?
Well, botanically a fruit is a part of a
flowering plant that disseminates
seeds, like an apple or an orange or a lemon or a grape.
In cooking, because they're not sweet,
we tend to call things like wheat grains
and bean pods
vegetables, even though they are actually fruits.
Vegetable is a culinary term for other
edible parts of a plant that
aren't fruit, like roots or leaves.
Corn on the cob
tastes like a vegetable but scientifically
corn kernels are fruits,
which means that corn on the cob is really just a bunch
of fruits
packed together.
One of the veggies we put on our pizza
is the mushroom.
Of course, mushrooms aren't really
vegetables because they aren't even plants.
They're fungi.
Names can also be confusing because of Stigler's Law -
our tendency to name things
not after who discovered them, or
originated them, but instead
to simply honour someone else.
Venn diagrams are cool.
They were named after John Venn in the 1880s,
although Leonhard Euler actually introduced them
in 1768.
And Avogadro's Constant?
Not actually discovered by Avogadro.
He proposed
that such a number could exist but it was a different guy
who discovered the exact figure.
Straight up misnomers
are my favorite.
French horns are not French
Your Funny bone is not a bone; it's a nerve.
The Ulnar nerve.
And this is not
Big Ben.
Nothing about this is officially called Big Ben.
Its real name is The Elizabeth Tower.
People often say that the bell inside is named Big Ben
but even that's not true.
The main bell inside Elizabeth Tower
is officially called The Great Bell.
The Great Bell's nickname is Big Ben
and we have since applied that nickname for a bell
to the entire tower.
Kosher salt isn't actually
kosher, it's just used to make things kosher,
to draw blood out of meat.
So really it should be called Koshering salt.
The Rocky Mountain Oyster of course
is not
seafood -
it's a fried bull testicle.
Arabic Numerals are not
Arabic, they were invented in India but introduced
to Europe by Arab mathematicians.
Haley's comet is named after Edmund Hayley
but had been witnessed by people at least as early as 240 BC.
Peanuts are not nuts, they're legumes,
and coconuts are not nuts, they're drupes -
stone fruit, like cherries, apricots, peaches, etc.
French fries,
as they are especially known in America,
are not from America
but were probably named by
British and American soldiers
during the First World War, who discovered
them where they were likely
invented... Belgium.
Now since French was the official language of the Belgian Army,
the soldiers may have mistakenly thought
they were in France.
Koala Bears are not bears, they just
kind of look like they are
and egg plants don't grow eggs.
Eighteenth-century cultivators
simply thought they kind of resembled eggs.
Dry cleaning isn't dry at all,
it involves lots of wet liquids but just not water.
And, silly guy, hamburgers are not
named after ham,
the pork product, they're named after
Hamburg, Germany.
Probably because at
Hamburg citizens who emigrated to the US
and brought their minced beef patty, a
Hamburg steak with them.
Guinea pigs are not pigs at all, they're just
similar looking to pigs - kind of.
And Greenland
isn't green land at all, it's believed
that about a thousand years ago
Erik the Red named it Greenland hoping that
the name would trick settlers
into coming over.
We drive on parkways
and park on driveways not because
work makers want to confuse us but
because the park in parkways
refers not to stopping a car but to the
nature parks
parkways often run along.
Skeuomorphs are design elements that
today are merely ornamental,
even though in the past originally
they had a purpose.
For instance, on a modern mobile phone
the icon for phone call is shaped like an
old phone.
The icon for e-mail
is shaped like an old snail mail envelope.
Or, when you take a camera phone picture,
you hear the sound of a mechanical shutter,
even if your phone doesn't have one that
makes that noise.
Older cameras did,
so the new ones do too.
It's a skeuomorph.
Your own name is a kind of skeuomorph.
Let's call it a skeuonom.
It was necessary at birth
your parents gave it to you but before
they knew exactly what you would be like
when you grew up.
You have changed since you were born
but your name has stayed the same.
When we called it
'The Moon', we didn't know that we would find
other moons in the solar system. When you
were named
no one knew how you would change, or what you would become, and you change
frequently.
You change many, many times
over the course of your life.
You learn things,
you forget things, you meet people, you stop
talking to people.
You experience things for the first time,
at a cellular level
millions of times a second you change
costume,
cells die and new ones are born.
And, at the atomic level, with the
exception of non-living
things, like tattoos and piercings,
every five years
pretty much every single atom in your
body is replaced.
So to what degree is the future or past
you, really you now.
Robert M Martin
puts this in a really cool perspective
in his book 'There Are Two
Errors in the the Title of This Book*'
"That person, who will have your name
in the very far future, will be connected
only very tenuously to the present you.
The person will remember very few of
your current experiences,
will be psychologically quite different,
will have a body that resembles your
present one only a bit,
and contains almost none of the same matter.
So it seems that this person is the
future you
only to a small degree.
In a way, in terms of memories and experiences in history,
you have more in common with a
stranger today
than you do with yourself 10 or 20
years ago."
Martin goes even further, saying why be afraid of death
if the future you who dies will resemble
you today
so little?
Well, to that I say
YOLO?
Well, it's probably more accurate
to say
YOLOBLOMLMTAASOSBTDPWKEOBOIODAW-
CHEOBOITOD.
You only live once, but living once means
living
many times, as a series of similar,
but technically different people, who
know each other, but only in one direction,
and who can help each other, but only in
the other direction.
And as always,
thanks for watching.